yay God no oh hello everybody my name is
markiplier and that's much hotter than I
remember
but one of the great things that has
been coming out in the pack hey one of
the great things that's been coming out
for me
uh-huh one of you guys is a new favorite
videos is my impossible let's play
videos that's why I want you guys to
help me out because apparently I'm
incredibly stupid and I need your
assistance on picking on what I should
do next so if you want me to do the mark
eat B's challenge click here if you want
here if you want me to do them
markiplier wrestlers wrestle a bear
while on a tight rope bonfire blow it I
don't know where it's gonna be we're
doing what dumb but either way it's not
that bad I only did it drop but you guys
have been loving the impossible let's
plays I'm not that terribly stupid
unlike what you've just seen which would
reinforce the idea that I am I'm smart
through the power of my patriotism which
is a good segue you know what I was
gonna talk about next I released a video
on Friday called markiplier history
lessons and it was something that I
spent about nine hours editing but you
guys loved it huh so a lot of you guys
have been saying that it's probably the
funniest video that I've ever made which
is really heartwarming to hear because I
spent so much time on it I had no idea
how people were gonna respond to it but
I'm so glad you liked it if you haven't
seen it click over there um you'll find
a link to it on it through an annotation
so I'm glad you guys enjoyed that in
other news the charity livestream is
this Saturday starting at 9 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time not Eastern Standard Time
so it's again not the same time aunts
not the same timezone so look up your
timezone online the charity t-shirt
design is here and it is amazing it is
the most adorable grunt from amnesia
holding an adorable kitten now we're
gonna be raising money for Best Friends
Animal Society which we've done
but before so I hope you guys will join
me and remember to check your time zones
check everything it's in Pacific
Standard Time starting at 9 a.m. on July
12th didn't mention that are they I
don't remember if I mentioned it but
check your time zone online because it
might be different than what it was
before so for this design you're gonna
have a white and a black shirt available
at now I've never had a white shirt
available so I wanted to people to give
an option for what they could have and
this particular design is so frickin
adorable that I don't know why you guys
so thanks again guys for watching and
supporting I wouldn't be anywhere
without you you are the most amazing
fans I've ever had and for all the
stupidity that I go through you guys
still enjoy the videos that I do so
seriously thank you guys so much for
your constant support you are all
amazing and heroes and I cannot wait for
the charity livestream this weekend oh
there was one more thing I do I forgot
something comic-con San Diego there's
some important information about that
I'm gonna be there first of all but I'm
also in booth 2 635 lots of saliva to
635 which is in between Marvel and Image
Comics there's a little image of the map
and an arrow showing where I'm gonna be
you're more than welcome to come up and
see me say hi I'm gonna be at the
zucchini spot red giant booth and also
there's gonna be a panel on July 27th
room 4 at 3 p.m. now I'm just hosting
the panel it's not specifically my panel
but I double-check with the people it's
red giant again and they're totally cool
with you guys flooding in there and
you're more than welcome to come it's
totally fine I'm gonna be hosting I'm
gonna be making jokes I'm not gonna be
doing hot sauce or eating bees or
wrestling bears on a tightrope unless
you want me to I can do all three at the
same time oh oh it's a brilliant idea if
you want me to do all that at the same
time
[Music]
[Applause]
on second thought maybe I won't but look
forward to more impossible let's plays
in the future along with more history
lessons for B on a totally unrelated
note I found this in the toy section of
a grocery store it was rated ages five
and up five and up and I thought this
surely was in bad taste because it looks
like an eco disaster waiting to happen
I'm not even joking
look at this it's oh god oh god I don't
even know what it is
it's like flubber but a dead flubber
rotting corpse of flubber here it's just
so weird
why would they give this to children
should I eat it you impossible let's
play eat black sludge challenge I want
to put it on my face I couldn't breathe
it's weird how that happens that way
I'll do it again
why does it seem like there's less of it
now both um I also have a green version
hang on right now
just keep your green tool dizzy kids the
oil
bills is perfectly okay and can be fun
and wholesome for the whole family
oh god it's radioactive ooze now this
really is the dead corpse of blubber
blubber you okay
oh no with these powers I combine to get
some in the dark forces of ancient evil
into my apartment it's like yin and yang
but actually snot and barf I want to put
it on my face again soothing eye mask
relaxing bud
I feel like I'm about to die I feel so
dirty why do I feel so dirty so thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video